hey guys Pete peppers aka flea bottom
Pete here today I'm gonna do a Q&A video
to follow up on my Lyanna Mormont
history if you haven't watched that yet
I'll add a link so that you can check it
out first I had a lot of similar
questions and declarations come up
especially about torment and mage which
I'll get to that last I decided to
combine the other things together that
kept coming up so that I could address
all the main topics number one what
happened to Lyanna Mormont during the
battle she was there to parley at the
beginning and then just disappeared I
just want to know she's okay well I made
the original video before the season 6
finale came out and we found out that
she was indeed okay during the battle
there wasn't much he could bring to the
table as a warrior so she was most
useful at the parley to show the show
that Jon and the wildlings had northern
houses that were willing to fight on his
side remember that the northern houses
didn't have much love for the Bolton's
but they did fear them that led to them
staying out of the Battle of the
bastards all together her presence
served to undermine Ramsay's authority
in the same way that her letter to
Stannis did earlier in series since
ghost was also very noticeably absent
during the battle we can all agree that
Leonin goes for playing fetch somewhere
while the soldiers were setting things
right on the battlefield number two can
she really just named John Snow king of
the north is it possible house moment
knows about John's parentage for the
first question the short answer is yes
because she actually did it in the show
and the other house has followed her
lead succession is a really muddy
process though where it isn't always
clear who the heir should be as far as
Winterfell is concerned though Sansa
clearly has a stronger claim since John
was never legitimized by a king also she
is Ned Stark's true born daughter and he
was the last Lord of Winterfell prior to
the Greyjoy's and the Bolton's holding
it question of John being the new king
of the north is really a question in
rebellion against the crown since Cersei
will never accept a bastard of House
Stark as warden of the north anyways for
the second question as far as the show
is concerned it seems obvious that house
Foreman doesn't know who Jon's real
parents are we know that John is the son
of Ned Ned sister and Rhaegar Targaryen
which would actually put him further
behind
actual children in any six in any
succession scenario all this will
probably play out differently in the
books but in the show what appears to be
most important
northern families is that John took out
house Bolton which makes them willing to
follow him against the crown number
three didn't gr moment take the black
because of a shame over jurors crimes we
don't have a detailed history of house
Mormont that explains this in great
detail but in the books it is known that
gr gave up his position as head of house
Mormont and Lord of Bear Island so that
juror could take over he did there
shortly before Robert's rebellion and
rose quickly in the ranks to become Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch Jorah then
shamed the house by selling poachers
into slavery to try and earn money to
keep up his wife's lavish lifestyle we
learned about this when Jorah tells
Daenerys the story of his marriage to
tool NS Hightower and we also learn
about it when she or explains his shamed
John Jorah was condemned for slaving in
Westeros and fled to the Free Cities to
avoid facing justice from Ned Stark
he left the ancestral Valyrian steel
blade Longclaw behind because he knew he
dishonored his house jira later gave it
to Jon Snow for saving his life he never
used the sword because it reminded him
George shame and knew that John would
put it to better use Jorah then spied on
Daenerys for beerus to try to earn a
pardon so that he could return home so
in conclusion jeera did not take the
black because of what George did he
simply advocated abdicated his position
once door came of age number 4
well Liana married John or Bryan or what
Littlefinger try to marry her - Robert
Arryn a lot of people want to see Liana
take a larger role and possibly marry
another major character others have
mentioned that she is too young to marry
any of the current characters since
stupid Rickon couldn't zigzag one thing
to keep in mind is that in this world
things are different there is basically
childhood and womanhood for girls born
into this system once a maiden has
flowered she is considered a woman grown
and ready to be married there isn't
there really like isn't a teenager phase
where kids go off to school and learn to
socialize and date that being said the
TV show made most of the younger
characters older for this reason
Dany is 12 or 13 when she marries Khal
Drogo Drogo in the books but in the TV
show she had to be older so that it
would conform with our cultural norms so
for lack of any other evidence as to
what house Mormont really brings to the
table as far as a marriage pact would be
concerned we can just expect that the
show won't be marrying off the
ten year old 10 year old girl 2ne1
number 5 what about her other sisters
now and the TV show it seems like they
simplified things so that she is the
only one who is left and the books
Alassane is in the north marching with
Stannis after he took Deepwood Motte and
desi is the only member of mages family
that's confirmed dead in the books
alison has actually mentioned as still
being around in the sample Theon chapter
from when's a wet winter that came out
too so on the show I don't think we will
see any other more monster-sized Jorah
and Liana though Jorah and is redemptive
argh possibly going east to get back to
Danny and Leona will just be the lady of
Bear Island and I don't think they'll go
into it any deeper than that
number 6 why don't we know who lianna's
father is couldn't they just be
following a matrilineal line or couldn't
it be the custom on bear island for
moment women to not take their husbands
names really I don't know the family
line of all Mormont characters we know
from mentions in the books isn't much
help either in general when women
married into a house and Game of Thrones
they take the name for example Catelyn
Tully became Catelyn Stark there is an
exception when marrying into the royal
line the wife does not take the royal
name so for example Cersei Lannister
married King Robert Baratheon but
doesn't become Cersei Baratheon this has
nothing to do with the fact that the
Lannister and her family name comes from
a great house or anything like that
she literally isn't permitted to take
the royal family's name to keep with the
last example Tully is a prominent house
just like starker Arryn but the woman
marries in and takes the name the best
guess as far as majors concerned is that
her husband's family name wasn't that
important for lack of a better way to
explain it in a few sentences their
children would be better off carrying
her house's name instead of his like
that doesn't make them bastards it just
makes them more month since we don't
have any mention of who the girls
fathers are or if they are the same
person for that matter the rest is just
speculation number seven tormund
Giantsbane is called the husband to
bears and tells John a story about
sleeping with the she bear since major
is known as the she bear doesn't this
confirm that torment is Liana's father
this this theory was mentioned more in
the comments than anything else so let's
see if there's anything to it there are
actually two theories about torn being
the husband two bears one involves maize
and one involves alassane I mentioned
the idea that I was saying
Asha Greyjoy that her children were
fathered by bears and that the Mormont
women are skinchangers in my original
video but let's talk about the mage
theory first since we're talking about
Liana's parents Barry Allen is in the
north and it can be accessed by water or
possibly even by foot if the bay of ice
was frozen and also Allison tells Asha
that the Mormont women are warriors
because they have had to defend
themselves from the iron men and wildin
Raiders from a young age so in general
it is definitely possible that the
Mormont family has come has some contact
with wildlings torment story has a
couple of details though that you would
have to completely overlook for this
theory to be true let's listen to him
tell the story I was in May ruddy hall
with only a cask of mead to keep me
company and nothing to do but drink it
the more I drank the more I got to
thinking about this woman lived close by
a fine strong woman but the biggest pair
of tits you ever saw she had a temper on
her that one but all she could be warm
to and in the depths of winter and man
needs his warmth the more I drank the
more I thought about her and the more I
thought the yard and me member got till
I couldn't suffer it no more for that I
was i bundled myself up in furs from
head tails wrapped a winding wall around
my face and set off to find him this new
was coming down so hard I got turned
around once or twice and the wind blew
right through me and froze me bones but
finally I come on all bundled up like I
was the woman had a terrible temper and
she put up quite a fight when I laid
hands on her it was all I could do to
carry her home and get her out of them
furs but when I did all she was otter
even than I remembered and we had a fine
old time and then I went to sleep
next morning when I woke the snow had
stopped and the Sun was shining but I
was in no fit state to enjoy it all
ripped and torn I was an aft mae member
bit right off and there on my floor was
a she-bears belt and soon enough the
freefall would tell in tales of this
bald bear seen in the woods with the
queerest pair of cubs Beyonder huh he
slept a meaty thigh would that I could
find out again she was fine today with
that bear never was a woman gave me such
a fight nor such strong sons neither
there are three things from torment
story that don't line up with his fee
bear being made Mormont
number one he says I was in me ready
hall with only a cask of me to keep me
company and nothing to do but drink it
so ready Hall is a place beyond the wall
he isn't talking about being on bear
island he's talking about being wherever
it was that he came from number 2 later
he says and soon enough to free folk
we're telling tales of this ball bear
seen in the woods with the queerest pair
of Cubs behind her again he says the
free folk saw the bald bear after she
left him this corroborate said he is not
south of the wall and number 3 finally
never was a woman give me such a fight
nor such strong sons neither amazed only
as daughters and torment mentions having
sons with the bear so that doesn't line
up either so really the only connection
the theory is the nate is the name she
bear and the fact that that he calls
himself husband bears the moments live
on bear island have a bear on their
sigil and so on but let's not overlook
the fact that there are actual bears in
the north so I don't see any real
evidence that makes this anything more
than just a fun idea
they are both colorful characters it
would be funny if they got together but
it just doesn't really seem to say it
happened torment has another nickname
tall talker and he's definitely not
Lyanna Mormont father they all the same
theory is slightly more believable but
again it isn't perfect at best there
isn't enough information and either way
since we're talking about Liana and the
honest parent theories I'm just not
going to go into it
anymore so that's those are the
questions I heard the most I hope you
enjoyed the Q&A I also had a lot of
comments about the sound and the audio
and the last video so I tried to fix
everything I could in this one hopefully
it turned out better thanks for your
feedback in constructive criticism I'm
hoping that each video I make from here
on out will be slightly better than the
last please like the video and subscribe
to my channel I've got some other series
I'm working on I'm gonna be doing a Tony
at harrenhal and a couple other ones and
also check out my jon snow dragon rider
theory I sort of mentioned it earlier I
don't really think that his bloodline is
is that important as far as ruling the
north or taking the Iron Throne but I do
think it's important and I think it's
going to have something to do with his
ability to bond with and claim one of
Danny's dragons so that he can fly talk
to you soon
your son was butchered as the red
wedding Lord monthly but you refused to
call you swore allegiance to house
star-crossed lover but in their hour of
greatest need
you refused the call and you lured
Kerwin your father was skinned alive by
Ramsay Bolton still you refused the
court but house Mormont remembers the
North remembers we know no king but the
king in the north whose name is stark I
don't care who's a busted that starts
good runs through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day
you